samedi dernier tf1 et france 2 avait
décidé de jouer au jeu des 7 erreurs
difficile de départager les deux télé
crochet qui avaient beaucoup en commun
sauf le succès alors que tf1 a décidé de
dégainer the voice all-stars avec des
coachs mythique et des candidats
charismatiques the voice all star c'est
une grande idée est rouge en delà de son
côté tout donné avec un nouveau format
lui aussi basé sur la musique 10
artistes ce battement de coeur c'est
peut être celui de l'un des artistes qui
va se produire ce soir porté par nagui
ce nouveau format très ambitieux reprend
à quelques différences près le concept
d'un télé crochet habituel ici
contrairement à the voice pas de photos
qui se retourne mais des étoiles qui
s'alignent est ce que la bonne étoile
s'allume
pour cela pas de stars non plus du côté
du jury mais des professionnels plus
confidentiels les artistiques
au festival de concerts de salles de
spectacles en revanche côté habillage et
plat tous les deux univers sont très
proches avec ses touches de rouge et
noir de noms anglais pour un seul succès
s'il se voit confirmer son leadership
avec kader neil simon téléspectateurs de
son côté coup dur pour france 2 qui n'a
réussi à fédérer que 1 million 300
étaient invités les spectateurs
pendant la bataille a critiqué et
aisément va c'était une création dont
ils ont planté quelque chose après la
mayo a pas forcément prêt tout de suite
mais oui et moi qui connaît bien la
musique qui je rappelle et sur la
tranche de skyrock entre faisant à 16
heures et 20 heures si je suis tous les
jours ça ne pouvait pas marcher the
artist c'est une catastrophe pour plein
de raisons déjà c'est beaucoup trop long
le jury est faiblard et troisièmement ça
se vend comme une émission qui met en
avant la patte artistique avec la plume
un univers et finalement ça fait des
reprises donc au final cette menace ou
the voice the voice all star c'était
vraiment beaucoup mieux en plus il y
avait un trek était de retrouver les
artistes the box hawkins qui ont grandi
et quand le nouvel nouvelle génération a
proposé en fait alors juste parce qu'il
est quand même ldd des effets de base
c'est qu'on sait qu un télé crochet
quand on commence on va jamais en direct
pour les nouvelles stars que j'ai pas
éventer il y avait la place de casting
était enregistrée il y avait ce qu'on
sait très bien qu entre ce qu'on va
découvrir ce qui va arriver sur scène et
parfois des changements et surtout la
plus le sont gérés 25 30 artistes très
compliqué c'est notre vision oui et puis
surtout qui est l'idiot qui s'est dit on
appelait ça six artistes moi ma mère la
ménagère par les djs et artistes
ma mère je lui dit sur france 2 il ya
dix artistes du nord mais c'est bon j'ai
déjà vu donc en fait ça n'a absolument
aucun intérêt
moi j'ai vu une belle très drôle sur
twitter the artist ça aurait pu être
mieux
donc on n y pas eu voice franchement ils
ont mis le paquet sur la roma sur la
première émission ce que je n'ai pas
encore vu la deuxième le jury les
exceptionnels retrouver à mme sylla qui
gérait sperme a enfin gagné ça marchait
super bien il y avait énormément
d'émotion donc du coup la question se
pose même et s'en fait signe qu'il va
pleurer sur tous les plateaux en disant
oui on a mis ça en face de moi on a misé
voice en face de moi parce qu'ils ont
peur bah non on n'a même pas pleurer ma
fanfaronner ça c'est alors pourquoi ça
s'appelle the artist a tout simplement
parce que le titre est court il est
efficace et surtout il est une volonté
d'internationaliser le format qui est
une création originale jamais je ne fais
je ne peux qu'encourager les producteurs
dénoncent des créations et surtout qui
met en avant sa mort il
faudra entre un petit pc panahi
piqueyrot perdant c'est la création
française c'est tous ces jeunes talents
et qui ont un talent incroyable qui sont
aujourd'hui mis en glissade alors moi
j'ai vu plein de choses passées par
exemple ils prennent ils prennent un
jury
voilà le jury ils sont pas très connus
c'est apprendre à gérer comme dans tout
les émissions du jury prenez un jury de
gens connus par le pack grand public
puisqu'il début ou connais pas les
chanteurs c'est la première chose après
le plateau est magnifique assez si le
code couleur rouge c'est pas trés ces
incendiaires dans l'univers se
ressemblent un peu de ça un peu à tout
ça a servi kessé canada dry mais ça a la
couleur médecin a le goût
trouve quand même très dur c'est qu'on
oublie le passé de nagui et c'est quand
même le présentateur d'une émission
musicale qui est rentré aujourd'hui dans
le commentaire de jolo patrimoine
français aux prêtres non mais taratata
c'est quand même quelque chose
aujourd'hui pour moi nagui est bien plus
crédible que nikos dans la musique déjà
c'est un passionné de musique donc après
faut aussi laisser le temps de
s'installer après leur jeudi
matin c'était quelque chose une des
séquences dans taratata
on voi pa ta tombe bien encore la
crédibilité de nagui parce que je vous
entends parler de nagui dont répond à ce
que vous dites la crédibilité de nagui
elle est là et vous pouvez dire ce que
vous voulez aller la voilà maintenant
maintenant en ce qui concerne l'émission
mois pour moi il ya que le rouge qui
pose problème sinon il faut lui laisser
le temps aussi de s'installer de se
mettre en place et il veut pas faire
face aux commandes on critique des fois
les émissions sur tf1 de prendre des
gens connus juste pour faire exister un
je vais reparler de the mask singer ou
je sais pas quoi ils ont mis des gens
connus plus connu que les les
participants ben là ils préfèrent mettre
des gens passionnés plutôt que des gens
connus mais elle parlait de crédibilité
mais c'est aussi la crédibilité du jury
ils sont peut-être pas connu mais c'est
les meilleurs amateurs programmatrice de
ses balles franchement on n'est pas au
loup on
connaissait
les bamanans bien mais des percées
excuse moi il ya ce qu'on appelle des
données personnelles est un jury qui
s'exprime si c'est pour dire tout le
monde a gagné comme à l'école des fans
c'est franchement sympa précédents jeux
et la ksa benjamin je redonne rebondi un
peu sur ce qu'a dit magali effectivement
ils ont tout misé sur night bus lui-même
mais on a peut-être mais oui chérie on a
péché par excès de confiance en disant
de toute façon nagui c'est un cador il
va nous porter l'émission ça va être un
carton eh ben non il suffit pas de
mettre un super animateur il faut qu'ils
aient un bon format et si france
télévisions et croyait tant que ça il
aurait peut-être pas justement réduit le
programme demain il n'y aura que 10
participants demain parce que c'est ça
s'est étiré en longueur sur une prairie
pas de bol ils sont pas censés
décroche
ainsi rappelé roux la star a quand ça a
commencé ça ne marchait pas apte au vol
il faut savoir que nos positions
il va juste et adéquate
ya eu des problèmes sur les paroles il a
trouvé le moyen de remettre au goût du
jour c'était à c'était un million et
demi d on montait à 3 millions donc
les règles à la copie c'est vrai que la
copie était un peu brouillonne mais ils
vont un peu tard en mai et comme les
autres services publics qui leur a tant
ils vont partir les missions d'un matin
mais surtout impuissant mais bon ils
vont passer tout de suite
ils vont attendre